like at the weed store they give you a
free joint you get a baby with a child
yeah but it's a they were cute white
babies I remember too I felt bad about
it who what's the cutest race of baby
black babies all the cutest girls always
say black babies you think Asian right I
do think as second very close second see
girls always say black babies I I've
always s Asian babies are the cutest and
then you know then they grow
up yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah if you could
just keep them that way I understand
that but the thing is is that what you
don't realize is that you look like a
baby that you
just
inflated a blow up baby I'm a blow up
baby really good like a bike
pump that's really good black babies
girls always say black babies yeah cuz
they are they're Asians are pretty close
though cuz they're just very we overfeed
them when they're young we just really
round we like them round that's why I
love that but white babies are the
ugliest thing
90% of white babies are gross looking
yeah because they're they're like
they're too like Gastly looking pres
presidents to me that looks like haras
Truman they do look like little
presidents yeah like exactly not not
even like cuz they're bald they're bald
their eyes are big and yeah they do look
like their presidents yeah white babies
are pres white babies are I've never
held a baby except for C-section babies
they always come out looking perfect I
hate it they I don't hate it but I'm
just saying they're perfect if it comes
out through the vaginal Canal the head's
all deformed and you know they look all
just you know weird
csection baby big head though C-section
baby yeah but that's your that's your
it's deformed no that's your
race that's your Filipino race the head
stay deformed it's just a momentary like
as it comes I'm not being racist but
that's just where you you're from the
country of origin Ian you would have
blown I mean I would have felt sorry for
your mom if she had to birth that head
no two babies C-sections yeah one of the
babies had two heads that was that was a
big issue yeah I mean is her vagina even
normal now or what
the tummy man oh that's right my my bad
he doesn't know what it that's why I was
asking I don't even know what c section
is where they they they put a hole in
the tummy and they pull it out that way
why why don't they do it the other way
um because sometimes the Mom isn't able
to birth a normal bird no this is this
conversation is happening also with a
parent and a six-year-old somewhere in
the United States why don't they do it
the other way same parallel grow up
now you going to do a call back because
I did the thing that cuz of your head
thing now you're going to do a call back
to I have to a call back all right
that's fine I'm going to let you have
one call back thank you one call back
Jesus Christ Jessica what Jessica on
your coffee yeah yeah because my
girlfriend got me the coffee and Jessica
bought it I know Jessica's her friend Oh
I thought you did that you said your
name was he has he has my um best
friends doing errands what do you say
when you get C what do you say your name
is do you say
Bobby sometimes I don't no what do you
what's your go-to I'll say something
that they can't even
write yeah yeah yeah yeah and they'll go
what and as they start writing it you're
like there's an accent over the
O you're not doing it right yeah ztu and
they go what and but yeah I do um weird
names or you do Andrew right I and I
don't uh I don't support corporate
coffee are
you excuse me no I'm just are are you
are you getting famous now oh my God you
know it's one of those things where do
you feel it yes no do you feel it no
dude no no no so you when you walk down
the street no one goes hey get a photo
with you no you know what I don't like
uh this is actually something that you I
know you know I don't like it when
someone looks at me and says to their
friend or goes and
goes and then the friend goes oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah I can hear them do that
right I've had that happen if any you
have to have that all the time if
anything just come up to me and just go
hey man whatever say whatever you got to
say and then leave there's nothing more
uncomfortable than I see someone staring
at my face yeah and
going is that yeah it's so I've had this
before is that yeah is that and then you
see their face go like
this like they angry about it right
you're like what did I do what did you
see me that you didn't like you know but
you can't even do that because that's
not even open so you just see like that
negativity Nega I always after his shows
when I go on the road with him and I go
to the women's bathroom after your shows
and I hear them giving their assessments
myaz and I can't say anything I couldn't
I can't [__] be like shut up [__]
you record that can't you record that I
mean I I should oh that's such great
material I know I know but I I can't
handle it he can't handle that I I I
just think that if they're there and
especially if I thought I did a good
show but you know you did a good show I
understand that but I still you know I
just I take things personally man dude
you can't people no I don't take any I
don't care you really you're like Ari in
that way I don't revie I don't read
reviews I don't listen to that stuff
like the cast on our show they're all
upset by some of these reviews that I
can't read that stuff I don't why would
I why do I care what one guy thinks
that's so weird to to like give credit
to somebody that's like one person
that's like here's what I here's my
assessment dude you could be the most
acclaimed journalist I don't I don't
know why I care why would I care yeah if
a bunch of other people are like I I
hate it too I'll be like no that's a
bummer but I I would that that's more
affecting that would more affect me in a
community more than one person typing an
article we didn't have a lot of Asians
man we had a uh
there was a rumor of an Asian when I was
first what was his name I'm not sure
what was the rumor what was the rumor
the
rumor was and I've talked about this
before I've talked about this before
um they had yeah they had a rumor that
there was an Asian kid right and this is
after cuz we got a Latino Kid we got a
Latino a Lao not a family just one kid
congratulations one guy one guy
uh Nicholas was his name and he had a
little bit of light facial hair
everybody was fired up about
that fired there was a lot of rumors and
stuff going around about that yeah um
cuz yeah people have never seen that on
children you know it was like would be
light hair on the face yeah like this
people were like he's trying to grow a
sideb burn on his on his chin yeah so
when I was on the wrestling team in
Middle
School um penas penisus right they're
cuz penas was 60% Filipino mhm their
wrestling team all the kids had
mustaches oh yeah all Filipinos had
mustaches by the time they're 11 I mean
literally we're female and male is it
like a hand print like a fingerprint
almost we just grow mustaches like but
we don't really grow the rest though
what we are like Manny Pacquiao
mustaches we all even the female always
mustaches but I remember like wrestling
against them the first time and they all
have mustaches right and we don't we
have we're like we're kids you're like
bro our but our team was so good yeah
that we we beat them even me I we
crushed them my
brother when he ever did um Chris is
that his name Steve Steve close close
well there's only three that's John yeah
yeah Steve Steve almost killed Steve
almost killed the Filipino out there wow
but my brother had no facial hair and
here's this old man with a mustache that
he's fighting against or wrestling
against and my brother snapped him on
the ground we're like yeah old man you
know what I mean that's what you get I'm
only 14 I know but it was amazing but
anyway so anyway so the F so the rumor
of the Asian though you heard a rumor
yeah they had a rumor that there was an
Asian boy in Slidel Louisiana which was
probably about 17 miles
away and so we had to get over there
yeah you know we were fired up and we
thought about it for a couple weeks and
then we started me and two of my buddies
cut grass man this kid Danny yeah uh who
was a good friend of mine and he had
some he had a couple of different
deficiencies but he's he's doing okay
now you know and he um we raised up some
money saved up some money over about two
months and then we caught a taxi over
there yeah and we went to this place
where they were supposed to have you
know this Asian boy Chad I want to say
the name was Chet I'm trying to think I
have to text somebody proba Chang does
that
sound Chang chaang yeah Chad Chad I
think right do ever do you ever see him
does that sound it doesn't sound it
sounds doesn't sound plausible it does
it does it doesn't sound plausible
because I've never met an Asian goddam
chat yeah there are in Southeast Asia
there you go it's either um I think it's
either Tai or oh well then he chatmate
bro
chatmate the rumor so but so we got
there and he wasn't there it was a uh it
wasn't there it wasn't he wasn't there
the name is from the city city of
Chester England so probably know prob
yeah yeah and uh yeah we went there and
it was just like a laundromat somebody
had opened up like a new laundromat or
like a cleaning like a right but there
was no was it the Asian run laundry mat
I don't know that could have been maybe
somehow that got diffused when by the
time it got toss you know I mean this is
way pre- internet you know right right
right this is back when you what was the
first do you remember the first time you
ever saw an Asian In the
Flesh man I feel like it was a man yeah
I feel like it was a man with glasses on
yeah but did I could probably draw a
picture of but I don't think that
I please I could but I don't think that
I could tell you when how old were
you after that I mean I guess I kind of
gave up on it after the yeah yeah
yeah after the no show of chat yeah but
you would think that you know go you
know saving up money taking a cab to go
see chat you don't see him that you
would years later ke to what when you're
going to see another AG so then when you
see another Asian at an airport or
whatever you would go oh my God and that
would be in your thing but that's fine
yeah yeah I remember uh went to Africa
one time as I got a little bit older and
I was like holy [__] you know a lot of
Africans are black you know yeah yeah
and I was
like and that's when I realized Like
Heaven is mostly going to be like black
and Asian people you know it's not going
to be that many white people there A lot
of Indians Chinese and black yeah yeah
it's going to be packed China has what 1
billion India has 1 billion and they're
dying are they dying pretty quick I mean
it's going to be packed up there when
you think about it well you think about
this too think about this I thought
about this is that you know how you know
when like white people they have pets
yeah they do funerals and they go we'll
see you in heaven whatever you think
that all the cats that are left and dogs
that's ever lived on planet Earth are
going to be in heaven too cuz if it is I
don't want to be there bro imagine that
just just everything that all the bees
that ever existed all the allergies the
allergy I mean it would just be yeah
yeah
5 4 3 2
1 why are you talking like that hey man
bro I'm singing a song in the beginning
you don't interrupt me until I [__]
introduce you
man uh we got Kila my beautiful Kila my
beautiful [__] Island Queen from the
mud rivers of of for the Philippines
we've got um wa does the Philippines
have mud River we got two-dimensional
face Gilbert can't see me yeah if he
goes to the side he disappears
God it's like a line is that a Brown
Line a great character on Charlie Brown
We Got U we have right here Richard
Ramirez he's back he's he's back
nightstalker is back yeah nightstalker I
actually don't like how he's in the
closet I know and we got uh his there's
a girl in there that's
like accomp George Kimo that's how you
pronounce it and um we got um very
special CU we've had him before this I
think this is the first time we've used
no we've used Assa a couple of times but
this is his um fat
Lando from from I'm not going to clap
there's a new movie called you already
clapped fat Star Wars and he's fat Lando
and um I'm fat Lando H there's going to
be um Cloud City you're fat Yoda [__]
that's who you
are oh yeah you can't even get on Luke
Skyrock back Luke Skyrock is like y I
don't know if I
get
how about we walk together bro it's good
it's good it's good I asked for it I
asked for it did yeah um so we got Eric
Griffin back and uh he's on a new
television program called I'm dying up
here and it's on Showtime and uh and my
special comes out July 7 no we're going
to do that [__] dude I'm sorry but I
don't know blow out your load it's so
unorganized it I'm not sure no see
that's the thing in the chaos structure
Asian intern you got yeah yeah
this is structur mud River over here I
don't know what we're doing yeah yeah
yeah and
um when I get my beard transplant which
is what I'm going to do I'm going to use
told this I'm going to use your knuckle
hairs I mean what the
[__] you going to say
that [__] mustache you have on your
face are you going to talk about this
[__] let me finish are you out of your
mind right now let me finish I know I do
look like I'm in mid you Haven evolved
fully know what I mean no this is like
right before the in the werewolf movie
right before the guy goes run you know
yeah you don't want to shave that [__]
or wax it I've tried then it turns into
your butthole yeah yeah yeah oh my God
that's so weird I just noticed that yeah
it's really bad because you're such a
big guy that there's just so much to
look at here we go so I just I slowly
noticed your Bobby per capita you're way
fatter you know what I mean what do you
mean like if you did like proportionally
yeah proportionally you're just like a
okay okay see this is don't make fun of
me from my dog this is 1950s
dog yeah a water hose is going to come
out
next you got to pick and choose your
battles you [__] battles she could
pick with me but the video game thing
you don't how how long has it been since
you've heard anything about the video
game cuz he doesn't play them anymore
yes he does all day ER not the good ones
not with
you you got to play Donkey Kong and [__]
in here if okay do you scream like him
when plays yes no you don't do no cuz I
hear you oh my God you know baby he
screams louder than me yes I'm yelling
we having a great time you don't know
how much we missed Bobby but you know
what to your credit he is a better human
being I can tell he's like more focused
I can't play Destiny with you because
I'll tell you why okay I I I gain
resentment deep resentment I gain um I I
start like kids you know when cuz
there's kids I play with on Destiny them
yelling at me and telling me what to do
oh yeah it was like literally kind of
going what the [__] am I doing BBY
remember when we started playing it was
just you and I and we were like oh we
got to get somebody else so we got Steve
in and then we got like oh that's when
Craig came in we we started to get all
these people but once we started
expanding into like people we don't know
I'm right there with you we were play
yeah but here's the thing you guys suck
yeah but it's
not we do we do so I mean when did you
ever win anything yeah yeah yeah this
one really let me ask I had to hear the
painful crying all I but the fun of it
was of losing all day Eric cuz we were
playing together it was the camaraderie
of it but here's the thing 600 a.m. in
the morning we played for 7 hours to
have you ever been to the lighthouse no
I'm never going to right why would do
you want to live like that I I listen I
totally understand what you're saying I
I no I get as equally as frustrated with
this [__] game I'm playing and I'm
like they're doing like trials or some
[__] and I'm like and I'm like I hate
this I'm not having fun like I'm
literally not having fun because there's
no way to get better at it like I don't
care like I change
controllers gun why would you want to
because I like playing with you
guys that's what it's all about yeah
Bobby don't you remember we became
friends because we were in the Middle
East playing Xbox on the road that is
true can you guys find a different
interactive game other than Destiny
where screaming we were going to do a
podcast together I see that I see that
you that's what we were going to
do until it's Yoko oo came in here
[__] ruined it but I'm not
bitter I remember when we went to All
Things comedy together I know we even
had a meeting sorry yeah I was in the
car when you made the phone call and I
told you to go to that meeting and you
didn't the second time around whatever
yeah anyway when's done is done bought
the mics when's done is done when like
when did you buy a mic oh oh see listen
okay baby baby baby baby baby baby
listen you are the best thing to happen
to this guy I recognize that him and
this room you think this room would look
like this it would be crazy in here if
it was just him we wouldn't be doing the
podcast be playing Destiny I still think
that you guys should do a podcast
together and I've always said it's not
too late I don't want your [__] pity
podcast yeah our kids went to Third
Street School on on Third Street in like
in like Larchmont border of Korea Town
wait let me ask you this is it private
school no public school this was back in
the day they're not go there anymore but
it was predominantly Korean right like
the kindergarten class was Korean
immersion so like your kid they cuz and
they taught math the way that Koreans
learn math is by by the way barely
listen to what I'm saying because I kind
of I don't know what I'm talking
about but but I think Korean Math's a
lot like playing the
violin okay yep wrong person I
think the same way to play the violin is
how you learn math and Korean and Asian
math is easier than white math don't
take my word on this I kind of listened
at this orientation math
math un let me let me say what I'm going
to say okay all right and then you can
say I'm going to call my wife well no
don't call your wife no because she
would know what I'm trying to say yeah
but what you're what I'm just saying is
that I thought numbers were a universal
thing no no no it's not but it's how you
learned the math how you learn the math
is very different because Korean math
was was easier to understand than than
uh Colonial math ah so so they would
teach them math in Korean and it would
and that's why math scores were through
the roof and someone's got to have my
back on this CU or at least explain what
the I'm fu is that kind of like how
rocky trained and Ivan Drago trained
right right Rocky trained in the forest
with logs on his back chasing chickens
and Ian Drago had
futuristic the wires and tubes and yeah
and it it is all based on the violin I
don't that makes sense when you're
playing music you see a note you don't
calculate what the note is you go oh
that's a B I hit a b so they the way I I
took kumons is three and two you don't
go what's 3 plus two you go the
combination three and two kum's Kum is a
mathematic like tutorial Center you
[__] I was sitting here hanging
out to drive for forever do this [__] I
want to see your explanation I want
[__] mother
I know what he just did and I want to
apologize what he did you let the white
guy try to hang him what you just did to
my friend right with sabotage and you
made him look like a fool and he's our
guest and I want you to apologize right
now Mr Cher I apologize thank you [__]
you knew I trying to say you know what I
was trying to say but I was bad at it I
was really bad so I I cheated so our
kids couldn't do it either our kids
couldn't do it
either yeah yeah yeah I want to take the
time to thank tiger belly fans because
um we did you guys were Relentless
especially on social media and whatnot
we're very relent yeah hashtagging all
that stuff and I some good news it's not
picked up yet but um you know we won we
won the we won the time slot two weeks
in a row nice and the numbers are really
good and um you know the one thing about
the show that if I'm going to say
anything about it's perfect the
showrunners the actors I have a great
time on it it's hard for me to figure
out how to become me on that show to do
what I actually do I might not have be
able to do that you know how like you
know how funny you can be yeah right and
then if you get a part where it's like
yeah I got to play so you're in this
part and there's not much you can do
outside of that you got to respect what
the writers bring go I don't want to
misrepresent how they see the picture
that's it's their project it's their
money yeah so I can't go out and go
crazy I mean that's the but you know
what at the end of the day you know I'm
happy to you know be in it and uh you
don't have ice how do you not have ice
in we don't we've never had ice our
fridge is from the 1980s how do you not
have why do you need ice I was going to
make another cocktail by the way then I
I yeah well you keep let me just cuz you
know I'm not drinking a vodka hot
soda Tamp how do you not have
[__] hold on hold on I feel like I
learned everything I need to know about
you
guys when when you wake up and you want
to drink you just go I guess I'll have
lukewarm water yeah okay so say wait
here no no stop friend stop friend I
want I want to stop you in your tracks
right now okay okay we have um rituals
that we have in this house okay and what
you're imply rituals rituals rual
rituals all
right all right let me say this yeah I'm
trying can you make this quick I want to
use
this all right my girlfriend and I right
we love cold beverages oh really you
don't yeah but but what we do is we put
in God this is cold we put it in the
refrigerator can you put everything in
the [__] refrigerator yeah yeah I
can't believe you don't like that do you
realize that would be a game changer
we're also Asians and Asians like proper
face you're Asian yeah youin whoa dude I
don't like the way you said that yeah
she's Asian
dude she's just mixed with a little bit
of uh French
oh say the other part Bobby she's half
Egyptian is that for real yeah half
Filipina I love Egyptians I'm mam Med
shout out to you my friend wherever you
are whatever desert you're hanging out
in right now he's in the Middle East by
the way I'm not saying that as a racist
thing he is out there he he's actually
out in Abu Dhabi or something so
whatever desert you're in not a racist
thing um God bless you and take care
okay this should be an interesting
cocktail someone want to go to my
sister's house and get
ice is it far she a block away you know
I I'll tell you another re thing is is
that we just don't use ice because I
don't drink you know that right no but
you drink fluids yeah yeah yeah but you
know we so we what we do is this okay
just just hear me out okay what we do is
we buy a bottle of water like this okay
yeah and then we stick it in the
refrigerator the refrigerator I don't
know if you know how it works but can
you start making ice maybe yeah it chill
are you sure there's no ice in there
there's no ice sweeti we've never had
ice we haven't made ice in 5 years yeah
do you understand yeah that half of your
listeners right now are going hold on
you guys don't have I like that's like a
but when we finally get it it's it feels
like such a treat like when I go to my
sister's house treat it's the art of
withholding she from the Philippines so
when I go get to my sister's house my
the first thing I go to is her crushed
ice ice ice machine I can't even say
that you never it's the most delicious
thing ever and I sit there and I just
crunch ice for like hours yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know you can have that every
day right no I don't want it then I
won't enjoy it all can I just say this
where do we get the one what do you mean
our fridge no is there a machine that I
can buy yeah yeah Bobby there is
actually I bought all of them I love ice
I've had I've had like three different
ice makers I'm thinking about getting
one installed in my garage cuz I want
the hardcore like the crush crush ice
Sonics but what does ice
do it makes this drink
science alert Al what it is what it is
is this is that what I'm saying is is
that I know when you put ice in things
it Waters it down or makes it
cold just makes it cold if you drink it
quick enough makes it cold so that your
tongue doesn't go hot that tastes like
vomit vodka okay I can't believe I can't
believe I got to drink this quickly I'm
going to get [__] hammered on this
podcast cuz I'm trying to chase the ice
yeah yeah let me just say this okay next
time you come over I'm bringing my own
ice no no no no I don't trust you I
don't trust you that ice that's a
challenge cuz let me say this right now
okay I'm a man of my word okay hear me
everyone back back up all right let me
say this right now [__] you will
have varieties of ice you guys have like
you with different like like cold grapes
oh we can freeze some grapes no you or
water you can freeze
water we don't have the ice ice maker
thing Cub the tray have the tray do do
we get one of those you don't even have
ice maker tray if we had a ice maker
tray we'd make ice [__] n BR look it's
the old one they are look that fridge
over there freeer top regular Bott
what's cold in there uh packs
of we might have something there we
might have something there yeah go get
them yeah yeah blueberries mhm how old
are these blueberries uh they're pretty
new about they're pretty new yeah they
might be a little frostbitten though so
good yeah yeah I'll take it you going to
put frozen blueberries in there
something to I also have Frozen coconut
in this is so this is why he would win a
race war this is insane race War what
doing it'll chill my it's as cold as
I yeah all right and flavored yeah this
might be the new thing so ridiculous
right there all right enjoy your
beverage that's not that bad actually oh
really yeah a little blueberry hint
that's actually really
good yeah so I get booked on um the
Oddball Comedy Festival yeah and I find
out that summer of
2016 yes this beautiful summer of 2016 I
remember it like it was yes couple years
ago a couple years ago
yes and I can't I couldn't believe they
asked me to do it but um so we go I go
to the airport and it's Sebastian
Mancala was there at the airport Tom was
there I think Dan Cook was there and you
know we were supposed to get our own
tickets so my manager Abby Juju
she's Jewish she wants to save money so
she always gives me coach always she
honey you it's not a big deal there's no
difference right yeah yeah
so now I remember yeah yeah so then
these guys get first class yeah so I'm
I'm talking to them in the you know you
know at the gate we're giggling they're
first class and they all leave and I'm
like now I blush and I'm going oh my God
I got to walk by them right right and
you know me let me say something walking
by I don't know how Christ felt when he
was like you know me holding the thing
and throwing rocks but it felt you know
similar I I would assume the only thing
I regretted in that moment was that I
wasn't already better friends with you
because then I would have enjoyed it so
much more you know did you just feel
sorry for him at that point no like I
cuz with a comic you already like they
let you know what kind of person they
are so there's some Comics who would
have given off the vibe of like don't
make this a thing and you kind of like
if you can pick up on people's you know
body language and stuff you're like all
you'd be like but he was playing into
like he was talking about it like I'm so
embarrassed and I was like that's a you
should be you know you're a piece of
[__] go back there yeah yeah yeah I mean
that's what it was they were like booing
did you boo I think they were Boo and
then we told the flight attendant to
bring you stuff I like go give him this
pillow yeah well no you came back and
threw a pillow on
me he took a first class pillow and he
goes hey use that you know what I mean
and it was just so embarrassing but then
that's when I knew that he was playful
but here's when I knew that I really
liked him and that he was a good guy is
is that apparently we were supposed to
arrange our own rides from the airport
we were in Austin yeah to the hotel
right and everyone got off the plane
first class you know when your friends
are in first class and you're in college
you would think that they would wait for
you to De wasn't Ally on the flight too
yeah yeah right no one did straight into
their limos they went right into their
limos that they their people set up I
don't have a limo nothing I don't know
how I'm going to I don't even know where
I'm staying all right so I'm like walkie
I don't see anybody and I walk outside
and I see Tom standing there with his
limo driver and he says I just assume
assume that you don't have a
ride and I go correct correct I'll give
you a ride to the hotel who [__] I don't
know who the I'm about to cry who the
[__] does
that I I mean no no make it who does
that I mean not only we're not war
buddies we wen't Nom together you I wish
I was you know but um I don't know him
that much I don't know him and he does
that that's [__] dope bro like I I
would probably hurt somebody for you
thanks buddy you're welcome man a
wonderful
guy do you know what I thought I
remembered though tell me if I'm wrong
about this I did make the Assumption you
didn't have the car and I waited yeah
didn't you come down and go like oh like
where's my car yeah he was like is my
guy here and I'm like I was like did you
book a guy and he was like no yeah yeah
I was like that you don't have a guy oh
I I I mean a normal comedian would have
fired it [__] people for that no dude
they just you know no it's no they they
they hung me out to dry are you now most
Asians as you know are really good at
the martial art which is your favorite
like of those okay now we're getting to
it now we're getting to the nitty-gritty
of it
all um just stop no you asked the
question I may I answer you throw the
Stars what is
it
um I'm Korean so delicious is it not
Taekwondo exactly I took taekwan do when
I was a kid yeah Master Hong Kong Kim
was my instructor a fat peran [__] T
no he was a he yes I was no actually I
was a pretty skinny little kid at that
age I was and then I got can I ask you a
question yeah you like the Andre ausy
look up that the head here's the thing
man the the thinner it gets yeah it's
good look but no if if it's when you're
thinner and you can let it go longer
it just looks thinner so like if you
have hair you go like oh it's just
parting and falling like you got to if
if you don't go short you're really
you're not doing yourself any right I
mean you can't let the wind pick it up
well you do what poly does and just get
the the the thing what does he do he he
take he what's it the the implants I
can't do it I just can't do he's going
to get beard implants I'm going to get
beard implants really what wait stop
stop stop stop why would you I'm serious
why would you laugh like that tell me
what you're so I understand what do you
planning on doing getting beard implants
which is like a hair transplant hair
don't grow
here are you serious yeah that's a good
idea I looked it up how much is it is
where to go is it a lot
6,500 that's not bad at all and it be
like everywhere now can I just say this
yeah just don't tell people that I'm
getting it done I know I'm saying it on
this podcast I understand that but
Comics don't listen to this so when I
have a full-on beard I want to show up
and have people go oh yeah he naturally
could do that you hear anywhere else not
much no on like maybe two in his leg
Yeah they take the hair from the back of
your neck and they they they put it into
your face and then you shave it
apparently and then you just let it grow
wild I want to look but you got to make
sure it go it goes everywhere right yeah
I'm not going to do blotchy like I'm in
[__] that's what I thought you
talking about Chernobyl I'm not gonna do
the Chernobyl thing I'm gonna that's
pretty wild dude I've never heard of
that what people get it I looked it up
on the internet is it popular among
Asians okay yeah because we can't do
like I can do this so what I'm going to
try to do is grow this out these tips
down here so it does a fum man cheu and
really perpetuate that look
yeah